next is gonna be Emily in North Carolina
hi Emily welcome with the Dave Ramsey
show hi game hey what's up so my husband
and I are we're just about finished with
the book but our biggest question was
basically we aren't starting with a ton
of debt we have about 80,000 and savings
we do have a car payment and we have a
mortgage I didn't know we should go
ahead and deplete our savings for our
car payments and then start building
like to be the best at or just go ahead
and just pay off the car payment and
which which book were you reading um
Total Money Makeover okay so go back and
start again there was a chapter in there
that told you exactly what today chapter
3 it said take all of your savings that
is not in retirement and become
debt-free and baby step 2 and so you
should write a check today and pay off
your stupid cars okay that's what it
says I didn't say stupid I said that in
a different I didn't write down I should
have written it but yeah okay and so how
much do you owe on your stupid cars so
we have 27 on the car that we need to
pay that's it 27,000 that's your only
dead except your home yes well like 1500
on a credit card
okay our main thing is losing budget so
that we aren't using the credit card cuz
before we were doing the whole oh we'll
use it and pay it off every month and
then tonight your children yes what is a
third on the way okay good one one five
and pregnant what time do they go to bed
I'm 8 o'clock ok at 8:30
you and your husband sit down at the
kitchen table and you have three things
you have to do and you can't get up from
the kitchen table until you do this okay
okay
number one pay off your car number two
pay off the credit card and cut it up
into little bitty freaking pieces okay
number three do the budget
the two of you while you're sitting
there and you get your every dollar you
get your every dollar app out and you
give every dollar a name because you
don't need a credit card you make too
much money you got fifty three thousand
dollar fifty two thousand dollars left
in the bank now right yes yes and we
have ten thousand that we've allotted
like towards kids and originally that
that amount that big chunk we wanted to
save for our forever home so why do I
get the feeling you're not going to do
what I told you to do at eight thirty
okay you just just ran off down the road
talking about something else as soon as
we finished just you're chasing your
tail in circles you think this eighty
thousand is eight hundred thousand it's
not you need to get yourself out of debt
put an emergency fund aside and then the
balance of that money can be your down
payment on your home and if you buy a
home 15-year fixed-rate where the
payments no more than 1/4 of your
take-home pay and I'm an old guy let me
tell you something there's no such thing
as a forever home everybody moves yes
very few people live in one home their
whole freakin life it almost never
happens it's just that that's a mess
forever home is a mythology it's just
it's this thing everybody says I'm a
forever home you're just not gonna be
because as soon as you build that your
dream changes and you're doing a
different one because I build my dream
home your dreams change thank goodness
they change your life changes the kids
grow up they move away the grandkids
come back now I want room for them I
need a yard for them oh my god I got a
dog I don't have a dog I got a horse I
don't have a horse your dreams change
right and so you know you don't you
there's no such thing as a forever home
there's a forever there's a for this
season of my life home and that's all it
is and it's just a freaking house and
there's one on every corner you can get
you a different one later so use that as
your downpayment above your above your
emergency fund
and above you being debt-free that's
what we call baby step 3b and that'll
move you to four five and six which is
kids colleges five retirements four and
start paying off that new house is six
you can do all of these wonderful things
when you start paying attention 8:30
tonight kiddo you have an appointment